on mélange en fête la randonnée et un
escape game c'est un peu pour attirer
justement les gens à venir sortir en
fait faire une randonnée les
participants arrivent ici à l'accueil
ils doivent télécharger une application
sur leur smartphone et sur cette
application
ça va les guider d'une énigme à l'autre
il ya 13 henning comme ça d'accord et
une fois qu'ils auront la réponse ça va
débloquer l'énigme suivante l'objectif
c'est de rajeunir un petit peu le public
les pratiquants de la randonnée c'est
quand même un petit peu assimilé aux
seniors en fête la randonnée les
familles qui viennent tout de suite les
enfants indiens et ben tiens prends ton
téléphone en parlant à leurs enfants et
puis c'est eux qui téléchargent c'est
eux qui gèrent en fait tout de suite le
téléphone donc c'est aussi ce qui va
attirer un peu le public un petit peu
plus jeunes c'est cette interaction avec
le smartphone justement et pas juste une
carte